foreign
45.
so
you okay yeah
3v5 set my shop got racked out how many
obesity of the intersection of 45 and
Crosstimbers
3v5 seven camera custody right now
that way
35 70 hft in the parking lot Chick-fil-A
it's okay
got a sunshine
okay
it hurts a little bit
see if I say am I still my partner okay
I'm gonna go check on everybody else
right now
going towards what 45.
all right
yeah
near Chick-fil-A
foreign
[Music]
man
I can't breathe okay
I'm not going anymore
foreign
[Music]
foreign
no
it's just a burn right yeah
our car got hit and my thumb got smashed
and I got hit right here I think it's
just a burn
yeah
am I good okay I just want to make sure
all right there's blood on him and him
right now
I don't know man we got T-Bone in the
intersection right here started running
after this guy falling down to gunpoint
look ambulance is right here
approximately 7 25 PM Phillip D Rogers
entered a department store on the North
Freeway wielding a wooden table leg
he approached a customer at the entrance
and struck the customer in the head
before walking out of the store
a Houston police officer working an
extra job at the store was notified of
the incident by store employees the
officer located Mr Rogers outside the
store attempted to stop him and gave him
commands to drop the wooden table leg
Mr Rogers did not comply with the voice
commands and began to approach the
officer wielding the table leg
the officer deployed his taser striking
Mr Rogers Mr Rogers moved toward the
entrance of another business a struggle
ensued when the officer tried to
restrain him Mr Rogers took the taser
from the officer the suspect struck the
officer with his fist and slammed his
head against a metal window frame the
officer discharged his duty weapon one
time at Mr Rogers striking him Mr Rogers
fled the location he was located and
taken into custody in front of a nearby
business by responding HPD officers Mr
Rogers was transported to the hospital
in stable condition the officer was
transported to the hospital and treated
for lacerations to his head and face and
for a possible concussion